situated above the arctic circle  pyramidin is home to the ghostly  remnants of a lost soviet industrial way  of life frozen in time  this now abandoned mining town was  established in the early 20th century on  the norwegian archipelago svalbard and  was named after the pyramid-shaped  mountain that looms in the distance  a walk through this place is a step back  in time to past soviet glory  remnants of soviet culture  art  and architecture still stand today  it is predicted that due to the low rate  of decay in a frigid climate the  abandoned town's major buildings will  still be visible 500 years from now  that's longer than any other modern  settlement on earth  you